We suspected this was coming.
The palpable conflict between what Donald
Trump has been saying and what Dr. Foushee,
the top infectious disease doctor in the country,
has been saying, the kind of.
Looks have been obvious for months, and yet
they danced around the differences.
Until now, everything that has happened to
Dr. Anthony Foushee has been absolutely embarrassing
for what it says about our country coronavirus.
PROTESTERS chanting Fire Foushee at their
protests, conspiracy theories about Dr. Foushee,
including bogus videos about Corona virus
that target him as a bad actor.
Senator Rand Paul attacking him earlier this
week, scolding him, saying you're not the
be all end all.
And now Donald Trump seemingly seeing the
door open to start more directly going after
Dr. Foushee has publicly broken with Foushee
in saying that don't Dr. Fouchier's claims
earlier this week during the Senate hearing
about.
We know we may not be able to open schools
in the fall.
Trump is now calling that unacceptable.
Unacceptable.
And what Trump means really is that it's politically
unacceptable.
And I'll explain why in a moment.
Let's take a look at what Donald Trump said.
Dr. Crouch is playing both sides.
Are you suggesting that he's surprised?
I'm not surprised by his answer, actually,
because, you know, it's just to me, it's not
an acceptable answer, especially when it comes
to schools.
The only thing that would be acceptable was,
I said just professors, teachers, etc. over
a certain age.
I think they ought to take it easy for another
few weeks, five weeks, four weeks.
Who knows?
Whatever it may be.
But I think they have to be careful because
this is a disease that attacks age and it
attacks health.
And if you have a heart problem, if you have
diabetes, if you're a certain age, it's certainly
much more dangerous.
But with the young children, I mean, and students,
it's really just take a look at the statistics.
It's pretty amazing.
Notice that Trump doesn't present any counterfactual.
Trump just says Fouchier's answer is unacceptable.
And that doesn't mean it is scientifically
unacceptable.
It doesn't mean that it is medically unacceptable.
What Trump means is it's politically unacceptable,
because if there's no school in September,
it's probably not good for Trump's reelection
in November.
If there's no school in September, that signals
likely economic calamity continuing to such
a degree that it's going to hurt Donald Trump
in November.
Trump also throws in there, by the way, you
know, kids are mostly fine and not affected
by the virus.
We've already covered that.
Children no one can spread the virus hugely,
even if they don't get significantly sick.
They could bring it to all of their homes
from school than their parents get it, than
their parents can't go to work, than their
parents can earn money.
You understand the problem of this.
And we are also, by the way, seeing a cow,
a sarki like disease in kids with corona virus
that still needs more investigation.
There's been several dozen cases so far.
We really don't know that much about it so
far.
Now, what this conflict means in terms of
Dr. Fouchier's future, I don't know.
One thing that I like in terms of breaking
from Trump is Mitt Romney.
We've been watching Mitt Romney and Mitt Romney
has started regularly ribbing Trump during
the Senate hearing earlier this week.
Romney actually asked Dr. Foushee.
Donald Trump has been saying Obama is to blame
for the fact that we don't have a corona virus
vaccine right now.
That's ridiculous, of course.
And he offered Dr. Foushee the opportunity
to answer.
And, of course, Dr. Foushee confirmed, no,
not having a vaccine right now has nothing
to do with Obama.
It also has nothing to do with Trump.
And I want to talk about that in a moment.
On a separate topic, my impression is that
with regards to vaccines, where I'm critical
of what we've done on testing, on vaccines,
we've done a pretty darn good job of moving
ahead pretty aggressively.
And yet the president said the other day that
President Obama is responsible for our lack
of a vaccine.
Dr. Foushee, is President Obama or by extension,
President Trump, did they do something that
that made the likelihood of creating a vaccine
less likely?
Are either President Trump or President Obama
responsible for the fact that we don't have
a vaccine now or in delay?
It is somewhat in some way.
No, no, not at all.
Certainly President Obama nor President Trump
are responsible for not having a vaccine.
We moved, as you said, because I described
it in my opening statement rather rapidly.
No one has ever gone.
So, listen, I like what Mitt Romney is doing.
I'm not rehabilitating Mitt Romney's image.
I'm not doing any of that stuff.
But seriously, who can deny that we would
be better off right now in this crisis with
Mitt Romney as president rather than Donald
Trump?
But to the other point that I want to make,
when we talk about we don't have a vaccine
right now, and that's not Obama's fault, obviously.
And it's also not Trump's fault.
I want to make really clear that you need
to be prepared for a new line of disinformation
that's going to start relatively soon.
Donald Trump is going to take credit for.
Seen when there is one, Donald Trump is going
to take credit for treatments as we find more
effective treatments.
And it has nothing to do with him.
Understand that it has absolutely nothing
to do with him.
We eventually are going to find a vaccine
and eventually people are going to get vaccinated
and eventually the pandemic will end in the
same way that on yesterday's show I outlined
for you how no matter what the death toll
is, Trump will say thanks to me.
It wasn't 2.2 million whether it was going
to be sixty thousand or one hundred thousand
or one hundred and sixty thousand or whatever
the number is, Trump will always take credit
for it, when in fact Trump's responsibility
is that it's going to be worse than it had
to be because of his slow action when it comes
to vaccinations and treatments.
They have nothing to do with Trump, but he
will eventually take credit for those as well.
Depending on when we get those things, he
will use them to justify his reelection in
November.
And he has nothing to do with why we don't
have a vaccine right now and he will have
nothing to do with us eventually having a
back vaccine.
Never mind that the vaccine that ends up being
widespread in use in the United States may
actually be developed by a different country
altogether.
Don't forget that stuff.
This is part of the disinformation propaganda
that they are using, which is deflect on any
of the blame.
Oh, listen.
The problem was Obama and governors, but we
solved it by after two and a half months finding
PPE for people ventilators.
Oh, yeah.
The problem was New York didn't buy a whole
bunch of them two years ago.
And this and that, the fact that we were slow
with the national stockpile.
That doesn't figure in anywhere and much the
same way.
Trump will get credit for the death toll not
being as high as it hypothetically could have
been.
Trump will try to take credit, rather, and
it's up to us to remember the death toll is
higher than it needed to be.
Look at South Korea got their first case within
hours of the United States getting its first
case.
Don't let them gaslight you remember.
I'm on Twitter at D Packman and I love hearing
from you.
Let me know what you think.